dahinter steckt natürlich ganz viel drin
in diesem exklusiv interview von paul
ronzheimer das ganze müssen natürlich
jetzt noch mal ganz genau analysieren
und zwar mit bild live chef claus strunz
bei uns im studio klaus was ist dein
eindruck von diesem interview
scholz schon kanzlertauglich hat er sich
schon kanzlertauglich gegeben also ganz
ehrlich guter typ ich habe dem jetzt
mehrere minuten zugehört und mir gedacht
ja dem kann man vertrauen ich habe ihn
ja schon länger im blick weil als
hamburger bürgermeister war weil ich in
hamburger journalist tätig und hatte
schon die nahaufnahme und er ist jetzt
sozusagen der hamburger bürgermeister im
großformat aber er sich treugeblieben
lässt sich nämlich in keine hektik
reinreden heute so morgen so und deshalb
ist erstaunlich dass er an einer stelle
nämlich dem versprechen es werde keine
impfpflicht geben sich selber doch
einmal untreu werden musste und dass er
merkte man richtig wie unangenehm eher
unangenehm das ist man gleich mal
angucken wir haben den clip vorbereitet
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir
auch einrichtungs bezogen eine
impfpflicht durchsetzen für die dortigen
beschäftigten der deutsche bundestag ist
da auf dem weg ich selber hat gesagt was
wir auch noch brauchen ist dass wir ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren auf den weg
bringen nur jeder abgeordnete nach
seinem gewissen abstimmt über eine
allgemeine also das erstmals hinter den
kulissen heute besprochen von olaf
scholz hat dieses thema angestoßen dort
in dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
mithalten neue regierung und danach
hierbei paul ronzheimer einem interview
also der künftige kanzler plädiert für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht und will die
durchsetzen indem er im bundestag frei
abstimmen lässt warum also erstmal er
ist damit einer der vielen im falle hand
vor noch wenigen wochen sozusagen im
wahlkampf genau das gegenteil behauptete
hat auch im parlament das gegenteil
behauptet und der hat jetzt um gedacht
jetzt ist die frage ist es zulässig um
zu denken wenn die lage sich ändert und
da muss man als erwachsener menschen
sagen natürlich ist es zulässig
umzudenken in der sehr kurzen zeit ist
es allerdings schon
bemerkenswert und
durchaus sozusagen kritisieren es wert
es haben sich ja die parameter nicht so
verändert ich will aber auch dazu sagen
dass der zweite teil den erwähnt hat der
macht ihn eben nicht nur zum impfen
faller sondern auch zu einem großen
demokraten denn er hat offensichtlich
erkannt dass es nur ein gremium geben
kann dass in der größten krise der
jetztzeit die zukunftsentscheidung
treffen kann und zwar das parlament also
wir alle ja diejenigen die wir erst
kürzlich dahin geschickt haben unsere
abgeordneten für die wir uns entschieden
an denen wir unsere stimme anvertraut
haben denen wir den auftrag mitgegeben
haben in unserem sinn zu entscheiden
denen legte die entscheidung diese
wichtige entscheidung der impfpflicht in
die hände und das finde ich nachdem die
parlamente in den letzten monaten und
man kann fast sagen jahren ja aus dem
spiel genommen waren nicht nur eine
große geste sondern eines demokraten
sehr sehr würdig jawohl dagegen kann man
nichts haben klaus und doch sagt er eben
das wird zur gewissensfrage gemacht das
heißt er öffnet dieser abstimmung ja
unter schwingt natürlich im köpfchen
immer mit na ja weil er halt in den
eigenen ampel reihen die fdp dagegen hat
im moment das heißt wenn er das nicht
machen würde möglicherweise gar keine
mehrheit für seine im labor stützt meine
these das macht ihn einfach zu einem
wirklichen großen demokraten er sagt das
sind die abgeordneten die die menschen
in deutschland dieses parlament gewählt
haben und mich interessiert jetzt nicht
das parteibuch nicht die
fraktionszugehörigkeit
nicht das pöstchen was ich kriege für
meine stimme das alles interessiert mich
nicht mich interessiert wie entscheiden
diese abgeordneten nach ihrem gewissen
und die frage ich bitte euch ist groß
genug und die verwirrung bei einem
selbst und in der unter firma wenn man
diskutiert und im sportverein wenn man
diskutiert ist groß genug und er hat
jetzt den weg gewählt der da hinweist
wie ein parlament eigentlich gedacht ist
ich stimme nicht wegen meines nächsten
jobs sondern ich stimme weil ich es so
empfinde übrigens auch raffiniert wenn
ein abgeordneter nur nach seinem
gewissen entscheidet dann muss er auch
nicht so entscheiden wie die wollen die
ihn dahin gewählt haben ein fakt ja also
das ist wirklich jetzt das parlament der
selbstständigen möge es auch das
parlament der selbstbewussten sein die
tatsächlich zu einer
gewissensentscheidung fähig sind in
dieser wichtigen frage denn das ist eine
ob man sich ein impfstoff sozusagen in
seinem körper spricht lässt ist eine
große entscheidung die man von niemandem
kleinreden lassen darf die sehr ernst zu
nehmen ist und beide meinungen sind
zulässig ich bin dafür und ich bin
dagegen und jetzt entscheidet der
souverän das parlament das finde ich
großartig gibt es denn im parlament
überhaupt eine mehrheit dafür also das
ist schwer zu sagen wenn die
abgeordneten diese chance wirklich
ergreifen wird es kreuz und quer
durcheinander gehende also dann werden
wahrscheinlich unionsabgeordnete deren
chefs der meinung sind es muss jetzt
eine impfpflicht geben plötzlich der
gegen sein es werden vielleicht auch
fdp- abgeordnete die er dagegen deren
partei er dagegen ist und dem parteichef
er dagegen ist dann dafür sein ich finde
das ist ein moment der demokratie ich
freue mich auf diese abstimmung und ich
bin olaf scholz dankbar dass er auf
diesem weg gekommen ist und ich bin
eigentlich erschrocken dass man das so
toll findet weil es irgendwie aus dem
selbstverständlich seien sie es muss
selbstverständlich sein dieselbe endlich
zieht die selbstverständlichkeit in die
entscheidungsfindung der deutschen
politik die bürger kriegen die stimme
eine mega diskussion auf jeden fall die
jetzt laufen wird bis zu dieser
abstimmung im bundestag die ja sowieso
längst läuft über die impfpflicht in
deutschland soll sie kommen oder soll
sie nicht kommen und da hat der kanzler
der künftige eben heute hier bei bild
live bei paul ronzheimer einen haken
dran gemacht ich habe mich festgelegt
sagt olaf scholz ich will die allgemeine
impfpflicht und er hat sich bei noch was
festgelegt und das wird heftige
diskussionen aus mehr die nächste mega
diskussion klaus und die betrifft den
impfstatus dann läuft der impfstatus
eigentlich aus gibt es dann darum dass
der staat künftig festlegt haben wir
machen was olaf scholz da eben gesagt
hat hierbei bild live wir wissen auf
alle fälle dass die jetzige dass der
vollständige impfschutz mit zwei
impfungen anders als gehofft im frühjahr
zum beispiel
nicht die wirkung hat dass er für so
lange zeit reicht und deshalb ist es
jetzt ja so wichtig dass viele
bürgerinnen bürger sich anstellen was
sie machen und sich ärgern darüber dass
es nicht gut genug klappt das ist schon
eine krasse ansage also wenn man jetzt
sagt gut nach sechs monaten ist das
ganze abgelaufen bei mir wäre das quasi
nächste woche der fall glückwunsch also
schließt aber gegen das anlassen kann
mir auch nicht sogleich wir müssen jetzt
erst mal die richtigen vokabeln dafür
finden es geht nicht darum dass olaf
scholz hat sich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ausgesprochen es geht darum
dass es sich um eine impfpflicht handelt
also das bedeutet einmal geimpft reicht
nicht zweimal reicht nicht drei mal
geimpft reicht nicht sondern wir alle
sind aufgefordert künftig ein impf abo
abzuschließen so wie man andere abos
abschließt alle halbe jahre wie lange
sollte es dann gehen das hat er offen
gelassen weil wir darüber noch nicht
genug wissen aber das ist schon jetzt
eine zeitenwende also eine bevölkerung
darauf einzustimmen dass künftig alle
halbe jahre gepiekst wird das bedeutet
man geht öfter zum impfen als dass man
seine steuererklärung abgibt das ist ein
völlig neuer look ist eine völlig neue
aber manche wird daher noch gefährlicher
für manche ist es vielleicht noch
gefährlicher als die steuer geben und
man kann nicht übrigens schon mit das
sei schwierig obwohl doch man kann die
entfällt also es gibt so viele
parallelen aber jetzt nochmal zurück zum
ernst das ist eine zeitenwende in
deutschland dass der künftige
regierungschef der künftige kanzler eine
impf abo logik ankündigt und das ist im
grunde ja das bisher schwerste geschütz
gegen dieses verfluchte virus das war
ein tabu bisher wir haben so oft schon
berichtet über genau diesen punkt wann
läuft meine impfung eigentlich ab und es
gab bisher von der regierung überhaupt
diese diskussion gar nicht das herz
schon spannend dass olaf scholz jetzt
derjenige ist der dieses tabu bricht
aber ich finde es gehört auch dazu dass
er dann jetzt in den nächsten tagen den
zweiten teil hinzufügt was das bedeutet
dass es wirklich bedeutet wir gehen
davon aus dass jeder mensch immer gegen
korona geimpft ist und das bedeutet dass
jeder mensch immer nur wenig mindestens
sechs monate abstand zu seiner letzten
impfung hatte ich kann mich nicht
erinnern und ich lebe jetzt schon eine
ganze weile in dem land das es sowas
ähnliches schon einmal gab ich glaube er
setzt darauf dass wenn dann die pandemie
besiegt ist man möglicherweise auch
wieder sagen kann gut dann reicht einmal
im jahr achtung wie bei grippe
entscheiden ist er jetzt wann er das
durch box mit den sechs monate ja was
mit denen dann passt das bedeutet im
moment bei 2g sind halt alle raus und
welche strafe die optimierung mit macht
er sagt dazu hat er sich nämlich
geäußert das wollen wir uns alle mal
anhören
wie läuft das dann auch wenn es eine
impfpflicht für alle geben die dann
durch den bundestag käme bedeutet dass
all diejenigen die nicht sich nicht
impfen lassen die müssen strafe zahlen
solche regelung werden damit verbunden
sein dass man das auch umsetzt gibt es
in deutschland ja immer zu viel muss ich
zahlen ungeimpfter darunter wegmann hat
regeln zu beachten das ist alles noch
gar nicht konkret festgelegt und kann
dem verfahren gemacht werden wir sollten
jetzt auch ernsthaft bleiben es geht um
das prinzip sehr ernsthaft der menschen
einmischen das ist es geht um das
prinzip buch das ist ein krasses prinzip
um das ist da geht das heißt ja faktisch
dass die ungeimpften danaben zweifel
nicht mehr einkaufen gehen dürfen und
dann müssen sie auch noch strafe zahlen
und zwar saftig tja also eigentlich zu
hause einschließen ja sehr viel mehr
möglichkeiten wird es nicht mehr geben
und ich finde halt diesen trick
oder den die verbindung so verrückt weil
es ist ja quasi für ungeimpfte in dauer
lockdown also aber man ist dann anders
ist auch für schöne der politik ja also
habt ihr einen dauer locker und für
ungeimpfte eingeführt quatsch dass mich
kopf gibt noch nicht aber wir haben
eingeführt es nach sechs monaten läuft
die impfung ab es gilt man als ungeimpft
und wenn man ungeimpfte ist darf man
leider nicht mehr ins theater nicht mehr
essen gehen nicht mehr einkaufen gehen
im bus fahren nicht mehr nicht mehr
nicht mehr nicht mehr nicht mehr nicht
mehr obst das ist ja der faktor lockdown
also ich appelliere daran sich dann
ehrlich zu machen dann muss man sagen
wir haben jetzt einen neuen kniff
gefunden wie man einen look down
einführen kann für ungeimpfte ohne in
lockdown für ungeimpfte nennen zu müssen
nämlich sechs monate gültigkeit bei
gleichzeitiger sozusagen zweig oder
zweig plus regelung wenn man der meinung
ist das muss man machen finde ich dass
bedenkenswert aber man muss ehrlich
sagen denn es ist schon eine große
freiheitsbeschränkung und mir fehlt
immer noch der glaube auch angesichts
dieser horrible zahlen die wir jeden tag
hören dass die verhältnismäßigkeit
zwischen dem geschehen in der pandemie
und dieser freiheitsbeschränkung gegeben
müssen man fragt sich auch wenn man sich
die ganzen schlangen im land jetzt
anguckt und saatgut alle sechs monate
soll ich mich impfen lassen dass mit dem
boostern klappt ja noch nicht mal gut
wie soll das überhaupt logistisch
funktionieren soll der ganze impfstoff
herkommen wie wollen wir das alles für
impfen wer soll's machen naja also sagen
wir mal der soll ihm auch schon überlegt
wie macht man das eigentlich immer ewig
warten muss und so also wahrscheinlich
muss dann der arbeitsminister jetzt zwei
tage im freigeben zusätzlich damit man
sich zweimal im jahr nämlich alles sechs
monate impfen lassen können das wäre
meine forderung tag ein tag frei dafür
bekommt denn manche leuten geht es nach
dem impfen wir auch wirklich schlecht
mir ging es überhaupt nicht gut danach
also eine also insofern wir sprechen
hier schon die wende wirklich also einen
paradigmenwechsel eine eine zeitenwende
und es könnte hilfreich sein
zwischendurch die impfzentren ich wieder
abzubauen man lässt sich halt einfach
stehen das könnte eine idee sein und
track gibt es bei und 8 6 monats abo
tatsächlich dass die kisten halt alle
sechs monate einfach aufgefüllt werden
und wieder neu eintreffen wie übrigens
finde ich auch eine interessante frage
ob die unternehmen die diesen impfstoff
gefunden haben jetzt grenzenlos immer
reicher und reicher werden können oder
ob nicht irgendwann auch eine
soziale eine gesellschaftliche
verpflichtung für die unternehmen auf
kommt dass die impfstoffe immer billiger
werden oder dass die renditen darauf
sozusagen eingefroren werden oder so was
die frage muss ich auch mal kommen das
ist ja jetzt das dauer abo für
rekordverkäufe wobei bei und ex steuern
gezahlt hat ohne ende und bleiben zu ja
auch zudem
eine frage ist spannende moment wir
wissen ja immer noch nicht wer
gesundheitsminister hat sich wohl auf
stolze noch nicht so vor dem gespräch
zumindest nicht ganz festgelegt stört
ich das ja das stört mich schon das ist
da ist er aber wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
ist es eine mischung aus es stört mich
wie verrückt und ist nötigt mir respekt
ab weil er ja so unter druck steht den
den mann oder die frau wahrscheinlich
eine frau wenn man durch zählt dass das
sozusagen paritätisch und divers
aufgestellt ist die die frau benennen
soll benennen die sie benennen sie sie
unter lässt sich nicht aus der ruhe
bringen und sagt das mache ich am
kommenden montag mit den anderen
ministern zusammen sie erfahren ist noch
früh genug die interessante frage ist
aber ja weiß ja schon wer nimmt ich kann
und weiß
ja ich kann das ist die frage paul hat
sie gestellt
die spd wird anfang nächster woche sagen
wer die ministerinnen und minister sein
werden die in das künftige kabinett
einziehen vielleicht darf ich darauf
hinweisen dass es beim letzten mal zu
diesem zeitpunkt gar keine entscheidung
über die bildung einer regierung und
überhaupt keine neubenennung von
ministerien ministern geben konnte weil
die verhandlungen zwischen cdu csu grüne
fdp gescheitert waren sich noch nicht
einmal wissen sie schon wer
gesundheitsminister der
gesundheitsministerin wird sie sollen
noch überrascht werden und sie werden am
montag hat carlotta auch noch einen
ständigen entscheidung von mir und von
der spd auch mitbekommen hat karl
lauterbach noch eine chance wir machen
eine gesamtvorstellung und wir machen
überhaupt nichts was darauf hinausläuft
dass sie jetzt nach topfschlagen prinzip
sich irgendwas zu recht sehen können
das könnte man auch einzelne arroganz
dass karl lauterbach ist der
verteidigungsminister findet das nicht
leicht von oben herab dieses
topfschlagen nein aber ich glaube er hat
aus hamburg kann ich berichten da war es
so als seine senatoren zu bestimmen
hatte hat das ich sehr früh für zwei
schlüsselressorts entschieden
das hat er aber eher in so nem wir haben
wie so ein manager einer firma gemacht
also nach qualifikation hamburgs
wirtschaft und kultur wichtig dass ich
für die beiden entschieden und ich kann
mir auch schon genau vorstellen dass er
genau weiß auf wiener dazu geht ich
glaube aber dass diejenigen und ich weiß
das ist wird aber das finde ich erfasst
das hat er fast etwas von der fernseh
show
ich frage mich nur warum sie das machen
weil ich glaube wenn er sich zu früh
festlegt dann hat er gleich die
personaldebatten und
man hätte beim gesundheitsminister wenn
man jetzt im sinne der bürger sicher
aufstellen wollen hätte man den den oder
diejenige vor die klammer ziehen müssen
und hätte sagen müssen das ist das
schlüssel ressort in der pandemie und
deshalb arbeiten jetzt der ehemalige
gesundheitsminister jens spahn und die
neue gesundheitsministerin eng zusammen
und machen es sozusagen einen übergang
in jedem unternehmen gibt es sozusagen
das der vorgänger seinem nachfolger ein
amt übergibt warum nicht dann in dem
wichtigsten der pandemie du glaubst also
es wird eine frau du hast gesagt ich
glaube es wird eine frau ich habe genau
vorhin zugehört was olaf scholz beim
rein und rausgehen natürlich nichts für
der hand logischerweise aber was hat
also ich glaube es wird eine frau hat
seinem namen eine kandidatin immer
jemanden ring schmeißen oder er braucht
keinen topf und du willst uns
aufschlagen zu machen und unterzog
schade eigentlich dass man eigentlich
sagen wenn sie meine frau geht ich habe
keinen topf da war ich stell dir stellt
euch nur mal vor er hat topfschlagen im
kopf gehabt weil es eine frau wird dann
hat er schon den nächsten skandal das
müssen wir aufklären da bleiben wir dran
wir haben noch eine woche zeit das zu
klären bevor er dann kanzler ist nächste
woche also ist es dann soweit der
kanzler scholz wird dann einziehen also
gut eine woche so ist es ganz korrekt
und paul hat ihn gefragt wie das
eigentlich aussehen wird wie das
ablaufen wird im bundestag wenn er
vereidigt wird
werden sie mit gottes hilfe schwören ich
höre so wie die letzten male
und das heißt ganz genau nämlich nicht
nicht mit gottesbezug so hat erst bisher
gehalten wie gerd schröder sonst haben
alle kanzler bisher so wahr mir gott
helfe gesagt den gottes schwur dort
abgelegt im bundestag stört dich das gab
damals diskussionen bei gerd schröder ja
ich glaube das wird keine große
diskussion mehr geben weil ich finde das
ist eine auch bei einem so hohen amt
private und persönliche entscheidung und
wenn er sozusagen das nicht fühlt nicht
empfindet und nicht in dieser welt sich
verankert fühlt dann wäre es ja schon
die erste lüge darauf zu spüren also
insofern finde ich dass er im moment der
ehrlichkeit claus strunz dankeschön für
den 1